je ne ressens rien jamais au final ça
fait pas de moi une mauvaise personne
seulement je dois faire plus d'efforts
que les autres pour être quelqu'un de
bien je t'envoie en pension après ça tu
te débrouilles race en moi tu es d'une
méprise
ça t'arrive de penser à tuer comment tu
ferais on a une proposition commerciale
à faire d'un flingue ouais j'ai un
flingue et aucune idée de l'endroit de
chiens ouest est un manga connaît rien
tu sais rien il ne faut jamais hésiter
la seule chose qui sort pire que ce
montré incompétent ou malfaisants sait
se montrer indécis
ok on y va
[Musique]
non
qu'est ce que je vais dire mais une
casquette
[Musique]